no no no no
non capisco cosa berlino nuova challenge
etica che ci avete richiesto in tanti
che oggi faremo i genitori per 24 ciao
ho ricevuto tantissimo il video in cui
ero in città di gemelli per 24 ore
avete speso centinaia migliaia di
messaggi che volete che facciamo il
video 24 ore genitori ho paura
si proverà non so di un bel mi piace se
volete vedere altre challenge 24 ore non
vi facciamo vedere nostra figlia e tu
vua nostra figlia se avete visto il
video in cui deprezzato decidono cosa
compriamo sapete che sono andati negozio
di giocattoli una bambola interattiva
perché abbiamo che sono bambole stabili
ma se persisterà ancora difficile per i
territori che questa bambola piangeva un
sacco di cose
andiamo ad aprirle vediamo assieme come
avrei preferito prendere questa con i
capelli castani e gli occhi chiari
perché somiglia un pochino di più ma se
restano questa bionda quindi nessuno
delle due biondo fate finta che ci
somiglia come giro per leo la nostra
figlia interattiva per ora non mi sembra
che sia molto contento sta mordendo la
scatola e ho paura che sarà super geloso
perché daremo un sacco di attenzione
lei è ovviamente faremo attenzione anche
a lui ma lui sarà geloso quindi esperti
non provi a mangiarla apriamo la
bacchettata ecco qua nostra figlia anche
tutti questi accessori e berlino non mi
sembra contento vediamo come la figlia
marina saggia da da dossi molto berlino
non si voglia per 24 ore
trattarla come se fosse il nostra figlia
dobbiamo rispondere a tutte le sue
ricchezze e cercare di proteggerla da
berlino anche di qua non ne abbiamo
neanche dato un nome a nostra figlia
no ma io non ti maggio
[Musica]
ok aspetta aspettavo berto team il
fazzoletto e non cambiano l'espressione
guerra c'è
non piangere cosa vuoi questo cosa che
puoi ripetere per favore
ciao vi presento il nostro cagnolino
berlino berlino queste nostra figlia
fatevi trattare bene grazie franchino
simone oberto la spesa meliora berlino
di qua no posizionarli non ci ha fatto
male aspettati l'oltrepò vetro
[Musica]
solo che non sia già morta meno male e
ben a 24 ne dovremmo sempre rispondere
alle sue richieste trattarla come se
fosse una bambina normale e cercare di
sopportare anche berlino che jean
gelosissimo merlino dai saf a berlino la
lasciamo fa appoggiata a dormire berlina
queste fa 100 berlino ok forse ha capito
che non ho mai avuto noi nostro figlio
non può essere chiara poverino per crisi
si abbatta male berlino
devi trattarla bene guarda facciamola
tenere un po a vitale il papa berlina
gelosissimo fazzolettini facciamo tiro
[Musica]
bravo ti ami controlla che sia tutto ok
ma possiamo dare nessuna cos'è questo è
visto di sempre mangiare priva di
berlino pensa che ce lo siamo
dimenticato e copiate e anima
ti ascolta il pollicino l'aspetto
estetico troppe cose ma 07 pure giro 7
pollici novellino non sento niente
berlino ti sei progetto inserita sono
[Applauso]
che riportiamo da a fare una passeggiata
fuori
vediamo il vento quindi un po di succo
[Musica]
però che mamma
meno male ore sta bene andiamo a fare
una passeggiata ma come la chiamiamo
diamole un nome perché io mi chiamo anna
ti piace il nome anna forse non le piace
un altro nome
il betta brutto grazie ai anch'io ora
andiamo a fare una partita basta un po
di succo è tutto viveri si piazza il
sole no non mi dire che forse troppo
prezzo
spero di no sennò come facciamo noi oggi
si è caldo infatti ora ti copro dovevo
portare una giacca in più
no non piangere non piangere non piace
verde sono semi le lacrime la vista e
bagnato tutta allora ancora che belle
parole che merlino le ha distrutte
guardate c'erano tante bellissime per
terra no venduto anche tutto il
vestitino dai cosa attenti di stucco
smetti di piante è tutto pagata faccio
tesoro tutto il vestitino bagnato è
nostri vestiti liber bambole che cosa li
metta tutta bagnata cambiar musica
c'è il solito non solo da sugar
ti fa piangere non capisco cosa sto
facendo di sbagliato ma non so ma dice
che si sente veniamo poi continua a
piangere ho detto tutto questo non so
cosa metterle adesso non penso di
poterla portare in giro così tutto
sbagliato bisogna che il voto che non
piace più poi che il vestitino e tutto
bagnato quindi se vogliamo essere dei
genitori irresponsabili dobbiamo
cambiarlo con qualcos'altro ha mangiato
anche i miei capelli
ok ho deciso di spendere in vestiti
dovrebbe associarsi poco tempo perché
c'è un po tutto le oggi è niente del
frattempo io dove tema così bagnata
sperando che non sbaglia ancora berlino
come reagisce adesso che è stato così
via
guerra a berlino la tua sorellina la
riconosci
ma che ha fatto niente
che chiarisce gli sta sciogliendo la
chicca mio futuro
dobbiamo andare a fare la spesa e
ovviamente dobbiamo portare anche lei
perché siamo genitori per 24 ore non
possiamo lasciarla bastona accaduti
imbarazzanti andare in giro che una
bambola repressore questa era che sono
bastati per mi piace scene pazze che
facciamo insieme perché non mi piace
acconciature ok ora aspettiamo che si
asciughi investito e poi andiamo al
supermercato con nostra figlia
ok ragazzi siamo in macchina a qua alla
fine abbiamo deciso di chiamarla né non
cosa avevi detto già europee francia
rude ma in macchina e siamo andati
supermercato spero che non inizia a
piangere adesso perché sono niente
no non ho portato di f l'ho portato su
spiagge sono propone a mamma sprovveduta
no non piagnere no rabbia c'era da zaba
di tutta la mattina
dai che ti accarezza però non piangere
però è di tutta la macchina ora 6 mag
r terra piangere reti beta si voglia che
impedire ma com'è che piange come una
fontana si mangia sempre tutto ok puoi
dormire adesso un pochino per favore
dormi un po almeno quando saremo in
pubblico dormi un pochino
è quanto dormono in genere i bambini non
dovrebbero dormire ha sempre un sacco di
ore bambino comunque è già difficile con
una bambola interattiva non piangere di
nuovo non piangere siamo quasi arrivati
dormi dormi
bello
[Musica]
allora vediamo se le piace qualcuno che
tu a questa bottiglia gonfiabile per
andare in piscina
ti piace da allora
[Musica]
una bella sì la palla mi piace questa
per mattino ma se non esplode quest'anno
tra i criteri che di ci prendiamo questa
palla percepire prendiamo qui anche nei
vestiti anche se non fai il tartan
giocattoli che cosa devi prendere le
bolle ti piace di me ma tu non hai le
mani che si chiudono quindi non puoi
farlo bene
6 ago questi cui berlino si rimanda non
va bene
forte troppo piccoli meno male non piace
quanto ti senti imbarazzato da 1 a 10 ma
mette troppo perché dalla fine stessero
galera
[Musica]
magari fatti vota da culla non trovando
non trovandosi addormento
ok siamo tornati a casa ma c'è un
problema anda non si sveglia più penso
che siamo riusciti a ucciderla è morta
secondo pensi mì territori misura dovere
di 24 ore anche se la scuola succede
niente
[Musica]
a berlino la storia che hanno poi si è
capito la pettorina e che stiamo per
andare forte
vediamo non piace
[Musica]
ecco forse ora non piangerà più l'ora
praticamente stavo dicendo che berlino
all'abitudine adesso perché stiamo
andando al parco e porteremo anche anna
con noi ovviamente una bambina deve
anche fare un giro fuori all'aperto
terra lo porteremo con noi e come sempre
le persone si guarderanno superstrada no
non piangere come carlo barrett e la
messa ci guarderanno comunque strano ma
sarà super divertente ha prima di andare
aprile due giochini che ci hanno dato al
supermercato e vedere cosa sto mese
piacciono a dan da merlino ti sto
trascurando tesi sempre il mio amore
lotito però non la sta toccando manuale
la stava sento tranquilla volevo aprire
questi giochini che ci hanno dato e
vedere se piace ma d'anna a merlino anni
vi faccio vedere che se ne ha già
mangiato mangiato rosicchiato uno meno
male lo abbiamo salvato giusto in tempo
allora abbiamo qua e una notte
ora che carina berlino se la vorrebbe
mangiare perdere un po una nota che
carina noi abbiamo già i fusilli e
il mirtillo che perché comprare la roma
ci ho messo un po a capire che erano dei
pugili questi pervengono duro di me
polese fra un albero quindi questo ce
l'abbiamo doppio ciao amore
forli nome sembra un po accanto a quello
stanco lo sente il rumore della gamba
libertà del cibo
vediamo cosa fa ha capito che la sua
sorellina il nostro trattato bene bravo
berlino bravo a non far cadere ordini
berlino berlino
ma per mettiamo tutte le barche di
volere bene tener vicino eccoci qua
eccoci qua siamo in macchina e hanno per
fortuna è tranquilla non sta piangendo
non sta facendo niente
forse sta nuovamente dormendo con gli
occhi aperti berlino sia offeso perché
su tavole attenzione a noemi ha girato
le spalle e ora non mi vuole più
guardare merlino berlino dai ma io
voglio però anche berlino portato questi
ribelli che siamo al parco con la nostra
bambina anna e berlino non felicissimo
ovviamente portiamo da fare una
passeggiata magari le facciamo fare
qualche salto per la cantera solito sono
i padri che fanno questo non capisco se
ha pianto e sudata avrò pianto
sicuramente devo poveri ma non parla più
troppa ogni tanto non parla
sì
mi spiace agosto che stai bene anche per
come pure è così e come troppo successo
niente dice che se poveri ma mi dispiace
che sei caduto ma ti do un abbraccio
forte forte è passato tutto il quadro
terribile asi farla saltare tu allora
adesso vedrai che tua figlia ad evitare
i racchettoni toccava che il sindaco per
l'irap in alto in alto vediamo quanto in
auto riesce a farla stare perché mica ve
dai in prova ha fatto piccolo ruolo
sembra dei genitori si è morta non parla
più però visto che ha vomitato campione
fazzolettino facciamo con il vestitino
[Risate]
chi sta vincendo vitalità come ragazzi
una brutta notizia
penso che quella caduta al parco
l'aguzzino rame
ho provato da mezz'ora svegliarla per lì
fare qualcosa di meglio
sicuramente c'è qualcosa che si può fare
[Applauso]
[Musica]
col cuore brotto abbiamo pure il
pannolino che non pannolino no no
per niente tanto mal di testa ma questo
attrezzo e rielaborando show allora ti
preoccupare ora ti sono costati così si
batte ma di testa né può essere conto e
forti sui fatti molto stretto questo
elastico perché si sempre raffreddata
dalla febbre
spero di no sono come facciamo a ecco
maria veglio lo sentiamo la cosa è molto
meglio
oddio sarà un po spettinati questi
cappelli hanno però forse forse va un po
meglio novi è molto più carina adesso è
perché non dormi un pochino così almeno
possiamo dormire tranquilli ogni volta
che la prendo io smette di parlare male
muta perché uno più bella macchiate da
oggi voglio bene allora com'è stata
questa esperienza genitori per venti
contrari è un po difficile 8 la traversa
supermercato che è stato substrato tia
spunto il pollicino pronto ancora si
cercò di gino seppur effetto da barbona
estrattiva essere giunto lì no
ed ecco quindi ringraziato i vostri
genitori quindi sopportano per mi piace
se potete vedere altre challenge
ventiquattr'ore jarrett tutti gli amici
nei commenti che altre challenge volete
che facciamo quello che ci piace di più
vi lasceremo un cuoricino e andremo a
farle sentire nordico dei tempi genitori
maravilla su quattro categorie giudicare
il nostro video cliccate su di te
[Musica]
nel cielo